el gobernador desde Florida el
republicano ron de santis ha firmado
este lunes una polémica ley que permite
que cualquier en el estado pueda aportar
un arma de fuego sin necesidad de un
permiso esta legislación que fue
aprobada la semana pasada por el senado
con 27 votos a favor y 13 en contra
entrará en vigor el próximo 1 de Julio
con Florida ya son 26 los estados que
tienen una ley de este tipo ambas
cámaras en Florida son de mayoría
republicana y es precisamente los
representantes de la bancada roja los
que han defendido esta ley porque
consideran que es algo que tiene que ver
con la seguridad pública con esta nueva
ley denominada HB 543 las personas que
lleven armas ocultas en público no van a
tener que necesitar ningún tipo de
capacitación especial tampoco la
verificación de antecedentes que es algo
que se estaba llevando a cabo hasta
ahora el gobernador de santis ha dicho
que el hecho de portar armas es algo
constitucional o un argumento más para
defender su conservadora de hecho él fue
el que prometió que firmaría una ley
para que los floridanos puedan llevar
armas de fuego sin ningún tipo de
permiso y es que el máximo responsable
político de Florida se ha basado en la
segunda enmienda de la Constitución de
Estados Unidos que da a la población el
derecho a poseer y portar armas aunque
no aclara si de forma discreta o
abiertamente los demócratas se han
opuesto completamente a esta ley y han
acusado al gobernador de Florida de
trabajar hombro con hombro con la
asociación Nacional del rifle que ya se
sabe que es un gran donante del partido
republicano advierten que con esta ley
se facilitaría que los delincuentes
pudieran portar armas además sostienen
que esa ley forma parte de las
motivaciones políticas para movilizar al
electorado más conservador del partido
republicana del partido de republicano
de cara sus aspiraciones para presentar
su candidatura presidencial para 2024
algo Que de momento no ha confirmado
rondes antes